- He over here talking about Drake,
he concerned about Drake.
I'm gonna tell you what
I'm concerned about,
making it to the john without
making a bathroom mistake.
- My left eyeball is fake.
- Sperm, my testicles do not make.
- I woke up this morning
and then my booty hole ache.
- Drake.
- I don't give a (beep) about no Drake.
- [Voiceover] Crazy, crazy,
this is crazy.
- [Key] Good to see you
old boy, how was Kenya?
- I love Kenya, absolutely
adore the place.
It's so important to protect them.
- Very good.
- The few untouched tribes left.
- Indeed.
- Yes, and while we're on the subject,
I've got something of
a confession to make.
- Oh dear.
- While I was down there,
I caught the attention
of a young Maasai woman.
- You didn't?
- She took me for an exotic,
sophisticated Superman of sorts,
and developed something of a liking to me.
- Well, isn't that always the way.
- (chuckles) Yes it is.
And it was quite awful Gerald,
she came down to my hut
wearing nothing but a
fertility head dress and
carrying a husband stick.
And oh, I had to
participate in the custom.
- Well, you'd be morally irresponsible
if you did not participate in the custom.
You could destroy their
entire social structure.
- Oh, I felt so terrible
about what had happened.
- Of course you did Gerald.
- I felt terrible seven times.
- But you know Gerald,
I too have a confession.
- [Gerald] Do tell.
- Remember several years ago
when I went to the Amazon?
- Yes.
- Yes, well, I accidentally
packed a lighter in my satchel.
- Oh my.
- Yes, well, one day I absent
mindedly lit the flint,
and the entire village took me for a God.
- Oh no.
- Yes.
Every sundown as I was being fellated
by all of the young women of the village,
which is the local custom.
I felt completely embarrassed
by the entire affair.
- I can imagine in some vivid detail.
But you can't deny the local customs.
- You absolutely, you cannot
deny the local customs.
- You cannot deny the local customs.
One thing you must do is
adhere to the local customs.
(men babbling)
Local customs.
- Local customs must not be denied.
- It's, oh, the least one can do.
- It all reminds me of the
time I was in Papua New Guinea,
and I introduced the local tribe
to the French term menage a trois.
After that evening a
couple of the local men
called me papua.
- Oh dear, whoops a daisy.
- Whoops a daisy indeed.
It's getting harder and harder
to protect the local tribes
from the influence of
the outside civilization.
- I know exactly what you
mean old boy, exactly.
And I must confess that the last time
I was deep in the Bush in Australia.
- Yes.
- I ended up deep in bush in Australia.
Booyah.
Well, where are you off to now old boy?
- I'm off to Tanzania.
- Tanzania, make sure that
you go during an eclipse,
because then everyone will
want to have sex with you.
Regrettably.
(men singing and scatting)
- I'll tell you, we still got it.
- Yes we do.
True that Waldon, we here, ain't we?
- Oh yeah, we hitting it and bitting it,
right now (indistinct).
(old men grunting)
- We out here straight
hitting the bricks as it were.
- Hey, I'm going to tell you right now,
I got a pocket full of nickels
and I'm ready to get loose.
- All right.
- Okay.
- Can I get another round please?
- Bop, bop.
I'm in the groove now, yeah.
- You guys like Drake?
- Drink, a drink?
We got drink.
- We're all sorted out on...
- We got them young buck.
- Drink front there tiny Tim.
- Drake, like Drake the rapper,
he's a musician, like started
from the bottom, now we here.
Drake.
- Drink, you saying drink?
- You know a musician called drink?
- You know what, never mind.
You guys are awesome.
- (scoffs) Drake, he over
here talking about Drake,
you guys are awesome.
- Nobody knows Drake, I don't
know nothing about no Drake.
I'm trying to watch my calorie intake,
we ain't worried about no Drake.
- Concerned about digesting my steak,
talking about Drake.
- I'm having a hard
enough time staying awake,
I can't be concerning myself with Drake.
- Poured orange juice on my Cornflakes.
- He talking about Drake,
trying to talk about Drake.
I need five breaths to
blow out my birthday cake.
- Let me tell you something man,
I ain't concerned about no Drake.
You wanna be concerned about Drake,
that's on your time brother.
Shit man, lost my teeth in a lake.
- I'm over here like a 1930 cartoon,
hitting my head when I step on a rake.
- What?
(Key squeaking)
- I don't know no Drake.
- He over here talking about Drake,
he concerned about Drake.
I'm gonna tell you what
I'm concerned about.
Making it to the john without
making a bathroom mistake.
- My left eyeball is fake.
- Sperm, my testicles do not make.
- I woke up this morning
and my booty hole ache.
- Drake.
- I don't give a (beep) about no Drake.
- About Drake.
(older man babbles)
Drake.
- Oh now look at the,
look at these two old timers over here.
- (chuckles) Now (indistinct).
- I will, I will brother, I will.
Hey, hello gentlemen, do y'all like Drake?
- Drake?
Hell yes.
- Started from the bottom, now
the whole team (beep) here.
Y'all like Tyler the Creator?
(bell rings)
(mellow music)
(man blows raspberry)
(bell dings)
(mellow music)
(slide whistle sounds)
- Wow.
(mellow music)
(slide whistle sounds)
- But babe, moving out?
Please, this is the worst possible time.
Please don't do this.
Babe?
Oh.
- [Mr Stanley] Garbage.
- Huh?
- Can I take your garbage?
- Yeah, sure.
- (chuckles) I find the
more garbage in the can...
The better it feels to dump it all out.
I suppose that's why we let it
get so full in the first place.
So we can start over.
(Mr Stanley clicks)
(mystical tune)
- Here to fix the copier.
- Yeah, sure, sure.
Hey, how did you--
- Sometimes things ain't really broken,
it's the way we treat them
that needs to be fixed.
(mystical tune)
(photocopier beeps and churns)
(Carl whistles)
(Carl chuckles)
- Who the hell are you guys?
- The important question
is who are you Steve?
Well, if it isn't Mr Stanley.
- Carl.
(tense music)
- You need to find your
own troubled white boy.
(tense music)
- I was here first.
Copy cat.
(Carl coughs)
- Sweep this.
(Mr Stanley grunts)
(Carl laughs)
(tense music)
Oh.
(Mr Stanley laughs)
(tense music)
(dramatic music)
(electronic fizzling)
- Damn.
Chesterfield (whistles).
- There can be only one magical negro.
(dramatic music)
(electrical fizzling)
(men yell)
(car alarms blare)
- Good lord, are you all right?
Well, I guess sometimes
things have to come apart
before we can put them
back together again.
- Oh, you're a magical negro too?
- Who you calling negro bitch?
(Georgina winces)
- Happy Sunday Esther.
- Happy Sunday, Georgina.
How was your week?
- Oh, the Lord is with me.
But the devil he got his
hands on my grand niece Grace.
- Oh no.
- Mm-hmm, they're smoking the reefer,
and doing the hanky panky with boys.
- No Georgina.
- Oh Esther, you know
that I love all things
that are good and holy.
But if he doesn't let go
of my grand niece, Grace...
I'm going to cut the devil's dick off
and shove it in his ass.
- Mm-hmm.
- With my prayers.
- I know you will
Georgina, I know you will.
- How was your week girl?
- Oh, you know me, I'm blessed
and thankful for everything.
- All right.
- But you know my grandson
Jason got his self
wrapped up in the leathery claws of Satan.
- Not Jason.
- He got his self arrested
for the spray painting
and the vandalisms.
- Oh lord.
- And I tell you I never
raise my hand in anger,
but if he don't let Jason go,
I'm going to punch that nigga
Satan in the nuts so hard.
And wipe the dick licking
smirk off his horned ass face.
- [Georgina] Mm-hmm.
- With my prayers.
- Amen, I know you will
Ester, I know you will.
But Ester, I gotta tell
you something else now.
- Oh, let it out.
- You know Ester that
I have found serenity
in the glory of heaven.
- Yes.
- But my daughter's husband Bernard
has got himself wedged between
the cleft hooves of Lucifer himself.
She opened up her laptop computer,
and found a pornography of women.
- Not the pornography of women.
- Absolutely, the pornography of women.
- Not on the laptop computer.
- The laptop and the pornography of women.
I am a pacifist under God's request,
but if he don't let go of Bernard,
I'm going to sneak up on
that bitch ass Lucifer,
right in the midst of his sleep time.
And then I'm going to sit
on that motherfucker's head,
and I'm gon' spread my booty
cheeks on that pig's face.
And I'm gonna just
pucker up my stank hole,
and just toops, toops,
toops, stoops (sings).
Until that nigga got a
brown dot on those nose
that I can use for target practice.
Sha pow, sha pow, sha pow.
- Ooh, shoot that nigga in the shit neck.
- With my prayers.
- With your prayers,
of course, of course.
Oh, Georgina, Georgina, Georgina.
- Yep, yep, yep, yep, yep.
- Oh, I got nothing but
faith in God in heaven above,
but I tell you my son's wife, Crystal,
she got herself wrapped up
in the fiery wings of
Mephistopheles herself.
- Here we go.
- She got caught using
profanity with her own children.
- What?
- At the dinner table.
- Oh lord child.
- Georgina Darlene Martin.
Oh, I have nothing but lovely
every creature on this planet,
but if he don't let my darling Crystal go
I'm going to flirt with the devil.
- Oh, oh.
- Show him a little bit of shoulder.
How you doing?
He goes to start looking away,
I'm gonna start twerking,
I'm gonna start twerking.
He's gonna be like, "Woo."
He's gonna be drawn in, seduce
that little motherfucker,
give him one of these.
Hi, batting my eyelashes at him.
Then, when he least expects it,
and I got his trust,
that's when I'm gon' ride on that nigga.
I'm gon' give him the night of his life,
a night he ain't never gon' forget.
I'm gon' give him this way,
I'm gon' give him that way.
And then right when he about to climax
that's when I'm gon' clench up my pussy
on that motherfucker's red dick.
And I'm gon' snap that nigga's cock off
with a divine kegel.
- Well, you gotta snap
that nigga dick off.
- Woo.
- Snap it off.
With your prayers.
- With my prayers.
- Of course, with the prayers, yeah.
But that's right girl,
you go get him Ester.
- Yes.
- Fuck Satan.
- Fuck.
- Fuck him in the...
(demonic whirring)
- What?
What's happening Georgina.
- [Devil] Georgina isn't
here anymore (laughs).
It is I
Satan.
(Ester shrieks)
(Satan grunts)
No Ester, I'm in here now,
I'm kicking this nigga's ass.
(Devil grunts)
- [Devil] Oh, help me, somebody help me.
I've got to get out of this bitch.
- Oh, get him Georgina, get him.
- I'll stick a safety pin
in this nigga's urethra.
(Devil yells)
- [Devil] Fuck, that hurt.
- Right now I got his dick
in my hands like an old rag,
I'm ripping it off, I'm ripping.
- Give me some of that,
I want a piece of him, yeah, tag me in.
(Devil yells)
- [Devil] Who's this crazy now?
- It's me motherfucker, your
worst nightmare (laughs).
That's right motherfucker,
I'm on top of you.
- [Devil] What's going on?
This feels good, why
would you do this to me?
- Oh you'll see in a second motherfucker,
you'll see in a second.
- [Devil] Oh, wait a minute,
oh, here I come, here I come.
- Here you go, huh?
Got the (squawks).
- Oh.
- Oh, I got him good.
- [Devil] I'll do anything you say,
I'll do anything you say.
- Too late now, too late now.
- We should probably go.
- Oh yeah, let's go, let's go.
- We don't want to disturb the service.
- I got a hold of him,
we gon' go medieval on his ass.
- [Devil] No, no, I
can't take it, I can't.
- Get over here (indistinct).
- [Devil] Please, please, get
these crazy bitches off of me.
Jesus Christ is my personal
lord and savior, I swear.
- [Ester] Too late for that now.
(mellow music)
- Hey Uncle Ted.
(Uncle Ted shrieks)
Oh jeez.
Woo, sorry Uncle Ted man.
- Oh Keith, I got you, didn't I?
- Yeah, you got me man,
you got me pretty good.
- Oh.
- What's going on today?
- Oh, just the usual young buck,
just another day at the laundromat.
While people come in and do their laundry,
we chat it up about some
of the topics of the day.
That's just another
day hanging at the mat.
(barbers laughing)
(mellow music)
- I wonder what's going on
in the barbershop today,
it sure looks like they're
having fun over there.
(melancholic music)
Forget all of that Keith.
Come on, we got our own assortment
of colorful characters
right here in the mat.
Come on.
Hey man, you need any more in quarters?
- Nope.
- (laughs) Okay, okay.
Hilarious.
Hey there Miss Dimitrius,
you need some more quarters?
- Oh ho, she didn't hear me.
- That's part of the problem Uncle Ted.
All that noise up in here
from the machines running,
and it's kinda hot.
- Loud and hot,
sounds like my old lady.
(mellow music)
(barbers laughing)
- Benny G Williams is in there now,
he's Lando Calrissian, he runs Cloud City.
- Oh yeah baby.
- Dammit Keith, what did I tell you?
We got it going on right
here in the mat baby.
- Uncle Ted I got to tell you something.
(mellow music)
I got my own washer and dryer months ago
I just keep hanging out here
because I didn't want you to feel bad.
- Oh, you didn't want me to feel bad?
Got your own wash and dryer, all right.
You're big timing me now, okay.
I see how it is.
Hey, well, your shirt ain't clean,
your pants ain't clean (laughs).
You can get a good wash on one
of them home wash and dryers.
- Uncle Ted,
I'm going.
- Wait, wait, wait.
Let's have some fun, let's have some fun.
You could get in one of the laundry carts,
and I can push it around.
- No.
I'm out of here.
- Wait, wait, wait.
Hold on there then Keith.
Keith.
- And if that don't work,
then you do a little tap
dance, and then you go
I'll be on the hands (laughs).
Hey, welcome to the barbershop young man.
- You're Billy G Williams.
- Yeah, yeah, how you doing?
- I'm good, thank you so much.
- Could you do me a favor?
Could you let go of my hand?
(barbers laugh)
(melancholic music)
- [Keith] Oh, thanks man.
All right, how you doing man?
(upbeat music)
♪ Baby, the funky train song ♪
(door knocks)
- Hi.
Are you Earl Peele?
- Who the hell want to know?
- I think I'm your son, Jordan Peele.
- Oh, okay, I see.
Come on in for a minute,
close the door on the way in.
All right man, go ahead
and have a seat there,
I'm gonna explain something to you.
- Okay.
(both sighing)
- I ain't your dad.
All right, I'm sorry to disappoint you,
but that's the situation brother.
- Are you, do you see what's happening?
We're doing the same thing.
I always do this,
I always scratch the
back of my neck like this
whenever I'm in an
uncomfortable situation.
- Scratch my neck, man.
Everybody scratch their neck,
I breathe in and out too man.
Now everybody my kids?
- Okay, look at this,
that's a picture of me when I was a baby.
That's my father.
- That ain't me.
Look, look, look, look man,
look that dude's Afro.
Look, I got this going on, man.
My hair is gray, he got black hair,
he handsome as hell but
I ain't nobody's daddy.
- I'm sorry.
I just been looking for him everywhere.
- Yeah, yeah, I'm sure you have.
- It's just I got my own TV show now.
(exhales) I don't know.
I know that wherever he
is he would be proud.
- You got your own TV show, huh?
- Yeah, I'm producing and acting.
- Oh, you producing and acting?
Right, okay, yeah,
that's my boy (chuckles).
Look at that man, we doing the same thing.
What is that?
Holy (beep), that's genes right there man,
because you can't do that unless
you sharing mad genes with somebody,
it's got to be in your DNA.
(gasps) Oh, you my son.
- No.
- My baby boy.
- Thanks for your time.
- You've come back home man,
I missed you so much little man.
- Hey, stop it, stop, get off, get off.
Get off boy.
- Oh hey.
- When I first came to your door,
you wouldn't even acknowledge...
Okay, you know what?
When I first came in here.
- When I first came in here.
- Stop that.
When I first came in here
you wouldn't even acknowledge
that I could possibly be your son.
But now only after I tell you
that I have my own show
on Comedy Central--
- Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, Comedy Central?
Get the (beep) out of my house.
(upbeat music)